au cours de ces conversations au palais
Karine bien entendu une nouvelle fois il
a été question du Vietnam au centre de
toute cette visite au Cambridge
d'ailleurs le Sud Vietnam c'est un
problème pour tout le monde mais il y a
un problème entre le Cambodge et le
Sud-Vietnam une reconnaissance de
frontière très discutée les Cambodgiens
disent que sur trois zones de plusieurs
kilomètres entre la frontière donc entre
le Cambodge et le Sud Vietnam il y a
périodiquement des violations de
frontièr cette frontière est mal défini
et le prince disait il y a quelques
jours c'est la force qui l'a défini cela
ne peut plus durer il y a d'ailleurs
aussi des problèmes de frontière entre
la Thaïlande et le Cambodge les
relations diplomatiques entre Bangkok et
P Pen sont même rompu depuis 1961 2 ans
avant que ne cesse les relations
diplomatiques entre Pnom Pen et Saigon
sur ce problème donc on a dit beaucoup
de choses il y a encore beaucoup de
commentaires à venir en revanche en ce
qui concerne les relations entre le
Cambodge et la France pas de contentieux
du tout depuis 1953 depuis que le
Cambodge recouvrer son indépendance
certes il y a eu une période un peu
délicate comme chaque fois qu'il y a
desconisations et puis après les
relations sont redevenues ce qu'elles
devaient être c'est-à-dire excellente
c'est ainsi que dans le domaine
commercial par exemple les échanges sont
au plus haut niveau la France est le
premier client et le premier fournisseur
du Cambodge et c'est important dans un
pays dans un continent plutôt où tout
est axé sur le Japon dont on connaît la
puissance économique mais d'ailleurs un
exemple de cette amitié nous l'avons eu
tout à l'heure lors d'une réception
assez
sympathique qui a eu lieu dans ce même
Palais Royal et au cours de laquelle le
général de Gaul après avoir été présenté
aux personnalités diplomatiques a été
fait général d'honneur de l'armée et au
cours de cette réception une rencontre
attendue dont on parlera la ré du
Vietnam à monsieurong le général de Gaul
dit simplement nous allons nous
rencontrer Monsieur le Président de la
République
qu'il me soit permis de vous prier au
nom des Forces armées
royales de digner accepter en témoignage
très modeste mais très
fervant de notre plus profond de
reconnaissance admiration et
vénération le TR Royal vous nomm général
suprême des forces armées royales du
Cambodge
mon Seigneur c'est un insigne honneur
que vous voulez bien me
faire de me remettre ce vire que j'aurai
l'honneur de porter et j'apprécie
d'autant plus cet honneur que je sais
mon Sene Seigneur tout ce que col depuis
sa naissance c'est-à-dire depuis plus
longtemps que l'histoire a eu le courage
de vaillance militaire et nous a encore
aujourd'hui je suis très honoré de vous
remercier et je remercie les chefs
d'étatmajor qui sont présents à cette
magnifique Céré un grand honur pour
nousés quelques heures après cette
cérémonie et comme il l'a précisé
lui-même le président de la République
recevra le délégué du Vietnam au
Cambodge
monsieur qui répond en sortant aux
questions de jean-pierreach et Maurice
ver le camb est notre voisin pre nous
sommes liés par une vieille amitié et
par des liens de solidarité et le
président de la République française
actuellement de
marque chef de l'État
nous soutenons quant à nous
aussi nous avons le soutien nous sommes
très reconnaissant de la part du
Cambodge pour notre juste lutte et
réciproquement aussi nous soutenons
entièrement la juste lutte de du peuple
frère pour la préservation de son
indépendance de sa paix de sa neutralité
et de l'intégrité territoriale du
Royaume alors dans ce contexte il est
naturel que je fasse une visite de
courtoisie auprès du président de la
République
française est-ce que vous vous êtes
satisfait de cet entretien vous savez
nous
sommes nous avons causé ensemble et j'ai
transmis au général de Gaul
les les habitiers de notre président re
on peutur Monsieur M dit monsieur le
ministre que vous avez remis un message
du présidentimine au général de Gaul
est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire dans
quel esprit ce message a été rédigé
d'abord je ne peux pas vous dire
plus de ce que je viens de dire ne me
faites pas dire ce que je n'ai pas
dit mais le programme officiel de la
visite ne prévoyait pas que des
entretiens et discours politique il aura
aussi permis au général de Gaulle
pendant 3 jours et à plusieurs reprises
d'apprécier le chaleureux accueil du
peuple cambodgien et ici pour y répondre
le président de la République a demandé
que l'on abaisse la capote de sa
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
voiture
[Applaudissements]